welcome to the show everybody on this on
this solemn day of remembrance 18 years
is a long time that is I know that's
what everyone is saying today but 18
years is a very long time I was in tenth
grade on 9/11 and now I'm 33 I've got
three kids going on number four and I
know this is again something everyone
says but it is I think about this a lot
that my kids generation will grow up
with 9/11 as an historical fact not a
lived experience but just as a matter of
history for them and that's very weird
to think about 9/11 to my kids is going
to be like you know what that was the
JFK assassination was to me growing up
which is I can remember growing up and
hearing my parents talk about it and
talk about what a what I'm what a
defining momentous event it was for them
but for me it was it may as well have
happened 6,000 years ago because it just
it wasn't it basically anything that
happens before you were born even if it
happened a day before you were born it
may as well be all the way back in
ancient times but as far as you're
concerned because for you the moment
you're born it is it's all it's all
after you know there's no before and
after it's just it's all after it's all
just in the past from your perspective
and that's how 9/11 will be and is for
my kids and all kids from now on but
those of us who are or older you know we
remember and I guess the tradition on
9/11 is to say where you were when it
happened so I was as I said I was in
tenth grade and we were in health class
I remember and and we were in the middle
of whatever lesson and another teacher
poked her head in and said to my teacher
you might want to turn on CNN and so
they turned it on and and the first
image we saw was the the first tower in
flames and then like almost everybody
else that day we watched almost in
real-time as the second plane hit then
within an hour maybe two hours we were
all sent home for the day I don't think
because they were worried that the
terrorist attack would happen at the
school I think it was just that there
was no hope of anything else happening
there was no hope of anyone learning or
paying attention to school that day so
they sent us home I remember the bus
ride
and the younger is another image that I
have stuck in my head from that day is
the bus ride home and the younger kids
on the bus were so excited and and
cheering about the fact that they could
go home early because they didn't
understand what was going on they had no
idea of the of the of the enormity of it
or really anything to them it was just
they got to go home for the day I barely
understood it myself
being 14 or 15 I was I was thinking
about this as well 911 is obviously a
defining news event for everyone who
lived through it probably the defining
news event but for me as a millennial it
was it was the the defining news event
of my childhood right as it was for
everyone in my generation and then I
started thinking about what are the
other defining news events of my
childhood and I think they would be in
order it would be Oh Jay I remember
actually that I was in elementary school
with the OJ verdict and they actually
came on the intercom at the elementary
school to announce the verdict and I
remember my teacher shouting an
expletive
in frustration and to me that was the
big headline of the day was that my
teacher said a bad word because I didn't
I had no idea what Oh Jay was or what
that was all about so oh gee then
Lewinsky then Columbine and 9/11 of
course than the Iraq war and then for me
the Beltway sniper I lived in the area
where that was happening and it was just
a surreal surreal time and those are the
defining events and it occurred to me
that that all of the defining news
events of my childhood are terrible as a
scandal and death basically and I think
when you when you think back to other
generations they had you have terrible
news events that are defining as a bit
but they're also at least usually gonna
be one or two good things like the moon
landing for example with Millennials
though all we have are it's all bad
stuff there was no real great
achievement some some some great moment
of national unity and celebration that
we can remember back to the unity that
we remember is
the unity that everyone talks about
after 9/11 for those few short
unfortunately months where people were
seemed to be unified but that was unity
brought about by a terrible tragedy so
not exactly the same thing as maybe the
unity that you would have had on the
moon landing or something like that
anyway I think that there's there's
there's you you could probably write a
whole book about the and probably people
have written books about the
psychological impact and maybe that
explains a lot about my generation I
don't know all right I'm moving on to
some of the some of the news events of
today of this week I'm not gonna spend
much time on this but I suppose the big
news story of this week is that
President Trump fired his national
security advisor John Bolton well Trump
says he fired him Bolton says that he
quit so we're going through that whole
thing again that whole rigmarole here's
the only thing I want to say about this
and if you're a member of the audience
who can't stomach any criticism of the
president if you're one of those people
who have who happen to have that what I
think is extremely unamerican attitude
where you do not want the president to
be criticized at all as long as he's on
your team of course if you're in that
camp then then maybe now's a good time
to just go take a bathroom break and
come back in a few minutes because it
might be easier for both of us less of a
headache so I don't have to deal with
all the the same old emails because look
first of all I don't care that John
Bolton is gone I'm not a John John
Bolton fan I'm not a war Hawk I'm not in
neocon I tend to agree with the
non-interventionist or at least less
interventionist folks on most of the
related issues so getting rid of John
Bolton fine
okay I'm that's perfectly fine with me
and and I even I think it's good
actually I support that decision
I did notice online yesterday most Trump
fans all Trump fans from what I saw
we're celebrating this saying uh the
president made the right decision again
hooray
good for him okay well here's the
question though in it I don't I don't
know why Trump fans aren't asking this
question I asked
of course but this is the question that
should be asked why did Trump hire him
in the first place so every time one of
these people are fired and everyone in
the Trump fan say good job firing him
why don't you ask what were you doing
hiring the guy to begin with yes John
Bolton is a war Hawk and a neocon
everybody knows that I know that you
know that everybody knows that
how did Trump not know it every single
person with with a brain in their head
when they heard that John Bolton was
hired by by Donald Trump all of us knew
it was gonna end this way we all knew it
we knew he was gonna get fired
eventually we all you knew it I knew it
we all knew it we we didn't even need to
say it we just knew it how did Trump not
know it isn't that astounding ignorance
on his part isn't that concerning here's
what else I know Trump has a habit of
making terrible hiring decisions hiring
either incompetence or people who just
do not fit in with his vision in his
policies such as they are and then he
ends up firing them as everyone knows
it's gonna happen and then the bitter
public feud begins and and this is just
not a sign of competent leadership
I mean hiring the right people that was
supposed to be one of trumps strong
suits oh I only hire the best people
right that's what he said I never
believed it actually would be a strong
suit of his but I was told that it would
be as a businessman he knows how to hire
the Rays gonna surround himself with the
right people okay well how did that work
out and most of his former employees end
up hating his guts how many times have
we gone through this or people that are
close to him and Italy and then they
leave and then there's the feud it's
it's not a good sign
okay and I'm sick of it I'm sick of the
same old routine the clown show I'm just
so tired I'm even more tired of hearing
conservatives make excuses for it and
and III it's just it's it's nauseating
to me at this point oh but I forgot of
course I silly me how could I forget
that of course this isn't Trump's fault
it's never so I mean he had a good
reason to hire John Bolton I'm sure he
had some good right we don't know what
the reason would be probably a yell
whatever he does that appears to be
wrong
there's always a good reason for it and
he's always the victim and he never does
anything wrong I forgot silly me how
could I forget that yes of course
there's oh there's always it's always
everybody else's fault always it's the
fake news it's the media it's the it's
never Trump errs all five of them it's
deep state his heads up consoie Lipa
lark inspiring and somehow forcing Trump
to do dumb stuff they're there they're
there somehow it's really them somehow
it's never him never I it was so of
course right right right silly me silly
me I I mean I I you know I almost made
the mistake of thinking that that Trump
is you know the present United States
and an adult and therefore could maybe
be held responsible for his own actions
and could be maybe be expected to make
intelligent and rational decisions about
who he hires I you know I almost made
the mistake of thinking that but but
silly me
how could I how could I think that yes I
your Chris oh you don't need to send the
emails because I already know yes of
course right right it's not his fault
it's everybody else's fault it's my
fault even it's everyone's fault not his
got it
okay moving on the brilliant minds over
at Fox I should say have a proposal Vox
does they want to lower the voting age
to zero yes 0 no voting age in other
words letting toddlers vote this is a
real opinion put forward by Kelsey Piper
over at Vox in a piece that was aptly
titled the case for changing the voting
age to zero which means even even
infants could vote
now let me skim through a few bits of
this with you it says in just over a
year American citizens will have a
chance to cast their ballot for the next
president except for the 75 million
Americans barred by state and local laws
from registering the vote that is are
there really that many American citizens
illegally barred from voting the answer
is yes our kids around the world almost
every country bars people under 18 from
voting the reasons vary they won't be
informed enough they don't pay taxes yet
they can't serve in the military yet
they tend to liberal they tend to be too
rebellious
the rules persists even in the face of a
generation of passionate smart and
informed teenage activist oh that wasn't
supposed to be a joke okay sorry and
even as it becomes obvious that our
current political system is failing our
children in the last year they've been
encouraged they're been encouraging
signs that we might rethink this
Democratic candidate Andrew yang is
argued for a voting age of 16 that other
people have argued as well well let's do
them one better the United States should
consider eradicating the voting age
entirely and letting every American
citizen wait wait a second why just
American citizens you fascist you bigot
who can successfully fill out a ballot
be counted what do you mean who can
sexist successfully fill out a ballot so
now we're we're excluding illiterates
should be counted in our local state and
national elections and then it goes on
so on and so forth okay so she gets four
reasons why we need to get rid of the
voting age here are her reasons number
one the whole concept of a voting age is
kind of unprincipled yes it does say
kinda she did right actually kinda ki
NDA the voting age is unprincipled now
there are long explanations for each of
these so I can read that the US
Constitution holds that the right to
vote cannot be abridged on the basis of
race color or previous condition of
servitude sex or age if you're older
than 18 it's an awkward exception we've
carved out to be to the admirable
general principle that just government
requires fair and free elections in
which everyone can participate number
two the case for democracy can't rest on
voters being rational informed agents
indeed there's a strong case for
democracy that doesn't so she's saying
no you know you think that that voter
should be rational and informed you're
wrong I'm going to debunk you then she
says number number uh where's number
three did we skip number three voting as
kids will turn young people into better
citizens and likely increase
participation their whole lives and then
number four kids have the same or even a
greater stake in political issues that
adults
okay you can go to Vox and read her
entire explanation if you really want to
it is good for left now I'm not gonna
harp on the irony here the morbid irony
that this writer considering the fact
that she writes for Vox probably is
pro-abortion which means she wants to
give voting rights to babies but she
doesn't want to give the right to life
to babies putting that aside I'm of two
minds here number one side of my brain
probably the more sensible side says
this is crazy obviously kids don't know
anything about the world they have no
perspective they have no wisdom if
anything which we were raising the
voting age so like 25 or 30 I think we
should be thinking about that or as I
have proposed keep it at at 18 but
Institute some sort of basic entrance
exam to make sure that the people who
are voting are in fact rational and
informed agents and in that case
actually now if you were to do that if
that's my idea now if we were to do that
then I think maybe you could get rid of
the voting age because at that point if
you're a rational informed agent go
ahead and vote so if you happen to meet
particularly rational and particularly
informed at the age of 15 you should
vote if you are not rational and
informed at the age of 50 you should not
be able to vote so I would if if there
was that caveat then I would be fine
with saying no voting age because that's
the main thing is do these people know
what they're doing when they go in the
voting booth
but generally speaking kids are are not
going to be in that camp because they
just they haven't been around long
enough you know it's looked like the
kids I told you on the bus on 9/11
coming home from from school celebrating
because there were kids they didn't have
any idea what was going on they have no
perspective they can't see beyond the
nose on their face and that's why they
shouldn't be voting contrary to the
claims being made here our democracy
does in fact rest on voters being
informed and rational agents it does
rest on that and now
the question is can date Canada mock
recei survive when the majority of
voters are uninformed and irrational
well I guess we're gonna find out
because that's where we're headed but if
it does survive it will survive in spite
of that obstacle not because of it it's
very clear that the best-case scenario
is where most voters are rational and
informed and also have a stake in what's
going on because they pay taxes they
have a job right that's best case
scenario and that's who voting should be
restricted to but then the other side of
my brain kicks in and I say actually
this maybe is a great idea maybe we
should lower the voting age to zero
maybe lower the voting age to zero no
test nothing just let everyone vote and
I'll tell you why because a child's vote
is really his parents vote a kid is
gonna vote however his parents tell him
a child's political opinions such as
they are are going to be 100% inherited
from their parents okay there is no
nine-year-old out there who who's who
who has their own political stance
that's completely apart from their
parents that they get it from their
parents so what that means is giving
voting rights to kids is really just
giving extra votes to parents now that
idea I kinda like so if you have two
kids then really you have three votes
because you have your own vote and on
your kids votes and those are by proxy
your votes I'm about to have four kids
so that means that I would get five
votes and really it sort of is like it's
even more than that because my you know
me and my wife are on the same page and
we have our kids so as as a family unit
we're gonna count for six votes
so actually okay I think I'm in let's do
it
let's go ahead and do that because think
about it who has the most kids in this
country conservative Catholics Mormons
Orthodox Jews they're basically the ones
having all the kids and I mean I run in
Catholic circles where where families of
11 or 12 even more are pretty routine so
this is a recipe for conservative
religious people taking over the country
I don't think the left the left has
thought this all the way through you get
rid of the voting age and then what are
you gonna have you're gonna have all
these homeschool families rolling up to
the polls with their with their 15
passenger vans and all of those nice
well-behaved kids filing out and voting
for the most conservative candidates
right tap the ballot that's what's gonna
happen and it you know I go to a lot of
homeschool conventions to speak and I'm
telling you those those parking lots are
full of 15 passenger vans buses little
mini buses and you think oh there must
be no there's a busses for in for one
family yeah if you want to unleash that
on the voting booth and then sure let's
do it yeah at a certain point I think
liberals are going to figure out or
we're going to have to figure out that
this plan of not having any kids and
even killing off your own young not only
is that morally deranged but it's it's
it's politically counterproductive
because you are you know taking yourself
out of the game as it were all right
what else we got here Antonio Brown the
wide receiver who forced his way out of
Pittsburgh went to Oakland forced his
way out of Oakland ended up in on the
Patriots the guy is clearly a jerk to
say the
probably a sociopath not a good person
but that doesn't mean we should jump to
conclusions on this news that a woman
and this was announced last night a
woman has filed a lawsuit against him
claiming that he sexually assaulted her
three times beginning in 2017
she says Brown assaulted her three times
the first time being two years ago but
the lawsuit wasn't filed until this week
until Brown was was was already in the
news what so it coincidentally I'm sure
right this happened two years ago she
did follow the lawsuit until Browns all
over the news just a coincidence
obviously right now look I don't know if
Brown is guilty like I said he is a bit
of a scumbag clearly so I'm not a fan of
his by any means that doesn't mean he's
a rapist and I read the allegations and
to me there are some serious red flags
here this woman was Antonio Browns
personal trainer she says she says he
sexually assaulted her while they were
doing training together a month later
after being assaulted she still went to
his home for some reason and was
assaulted again and then awhile after
that after being allegedly assaulted two
times she went out she went out on the
town with him she went like clubbing or
something and then goes back to his
house and his assaulted a third time
this doesn't make any sense to me I'm
sorry I I know I
that makes no there's there's more going
on here Adam at a minimum because that
doesn't make any sense
and every time I hear stories like this
it just now I question this story on
Twitter last night and a bunch of people
scolded me saying how dare you how dare
you judge this woman victim blaming so
on and so forth
sometimes women stay with their abusers
it's complicated you can't judge and yes
I realize that sometimes a woman might
stay uh oftentimes you hear about these
cases where a woman stays with an
abusive husband or even boyfriend who
she's living with because she feels
trapped and you know they have kids and
and all of that and it's a terrible
situation to be in I'm sure and the
blame is entirely on the abuser there of
course but that's not what's going on
here okay this is not they aren't
married they weren't dating as far as we
know she was just his trainer this was
basically a casual relationship and yet
she goes back to him after being
assaulted is assaulted again then goes
back to him again and his assaulted
again who in their right mind would
behave that way I ask you any woman
watching this would you casually get
together with a guy who had assaulted
you twice and not only get together with
him but go back to his house after a
night out on the town um he she says she
only went back to his house to use the
bathroom or something because there were
no bathrooms where she was she had no no
choice but to go back to the guy's house
who she says an assaulter twice already
I it just is there any way in hell I
mean I'm asking you as a woman if your
watch if you're watching this in your
woman is there any way in hell you would
casually get together with some guy who
assaulted you twice already and go back
to his house so my question
it's a red flag it's not victim-blaming
it's not victim-blaming because i'm
questioning whether or not she actually
was a victim whether or not this this
story is true we can't just assume that
it is we can't necessarily assume that
it isn't but we have to look at the
story as its presented to us and given
the information we know now figure out
which direction it most plausibly points
could be true it could it could not be
true but what's more plausible that a
woman would be assaulted by a man and
then go back to his house anyway get
assaulted again and then go back to his
house a third time
is that more plausible than the
possibility that she might be
fabricating some of this because he's
rich and he's in the news and also this
is a perfect time to file a lawsuit like
this because everyone's against him and
you know so so which is more plausible
that's that's the question and I think
probably the latter right now is more
plausible finally before we get to some
emails here let me share one other thing
with you and this is real okay this is
not parodies isn't satire reading from
the hill same-sex penguin couple to
raise first gender-neutral chick at
London Aquarium it says the same-sex
penguin couple will raise what may be
the world's first genderless chick a
London Aquarium announced Tuesday the
four month old baby will be raised by
two female penguins rocky and Maremma at
Sea Life London without a gendered name
or a specified gender general manager
Graham McGrath said while the decision
may ruffle a few feathers get the pun
they're very good gender neutrality and
humans has only recently become a
widespread topic of conversation however
it is completely natural for penguins to
develop genderless identities as they
grow into mature adults I know what
you're thinking when you when you hear
that I know exactly what you think
you're thinking it's great that they're
letting it be gender-neutral but what
kind of fascist assigns a speech
in the first place I mean how do they
know that it's a penguin is that rather
presumptuous to sit here and say oh
we've got this penguin chick I mean good
for you fascists for sago we're not
gonna call it male or female good for
you well done let me get you a cookie
meanwhile you are consigning it to a
life as a penguin having not asked it
what it prefers to be how do you know it
could be a buffalo there it could be it
could be a tarantula
it could be a three-toed sloth it could
be a middle-aged Korean man you don't
know you haven't asked and yet you just
assume that it wants to live life as a
penguin maybe it wants to be out on the
plains
you know skipping through the fields
like a gazelle maybe he wants to be
climbing a tree like a spider monkey you
don't know because you didn't ask you
bigots outrageous sorry I'm a little
heated I just when I see this kind of
closed-minded thinking in people it
sends me through the roof this is what
it's like to be to be so much more
enlightened than everybody else
as I am this is the this is the burden
this is the cross that I carry in my
life as a squirrel let's go to emails
hello Matt now this is for Mike says
hello Matt I am I am and have been an
atheist for much of my life Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com is the email daily
hello Matt I am and have been an atheist
much my life despite growing up in a
Roman Catholic family and a largely
Christian community recently however I
am finding that I would like to pursue
faith and bring God into my life the
part I'm struggling with and where I
would appreciate your insight is some
prominent scientific discoveries seem to
contradict the existence of a god or at
least come into conflict largely with
the book of Genesis
I've talked to some individuals in my
community about this and I've generally
been urged to toss certain scientific
discoveries to the side as nonsense such
as evolution in favor of blind biblical
readings I cannot simply turn a blind
eye to scientific discovery and I'm not
sure where faith and science coincide
what are your thoughts and where can I
look for answers in this regard I felt
turning to your view would be a good
start as you have in the past at least
recognized where and how some views of
faith fall short alright Mike well first
it's great that you're thinking about
these things and you're turning this
over in your head and as I say to
everybody who sends me emails like this
I think that that's you should be
applauded for that because now you'd
like to think that everyone thinks about
these things and is working them out and
think you know you like because for you
it comes naturally right but I think
most people live their lives and just
don't even think about it so that's good
the people telling you to toss science
to the side I don't know if that's a
verbatim quote you're giving me I
suspect it isn't but if that's the if
that's the general attitude approach
that you're hearing from from I guess
Christians you've talked to telling you
to forget about the science well those
are people that you shouldn't take
seriously I I would recommend it
strongly I would plead with you actually
to not talk to them any more about this
you do what you want but it doesn't
sound like those are the kinds of people
they they're just these are not
thoughtful people if that's what they're
saying to you science is not some sort
of Fringe subject that you could take or
leave you can't say well science science
science science is how the world works
okay it is the study the exploration the
discovery the explanation of how the
physical world works
that's all science is so tossing science
to the side is like it's like it's a is
you might as well say you're tossing
gravity to the side gravity which has
been discovered and explained through
science but you can't
right you can't toss gravity to the side
all you could do is delude yourself try
to delude yourself into believing it
doesn't exist but it still exists it
still just is so that's not a good use
of your time I would say then don't toss
science to the side instead I would
explore the ways in which both science
and faith can not only coexist but
support one another because there's no
reason to try to find there's no reason
why the two concepts have to contradict
or be at odds so I would I would that's
what that's what I would do and I would
start I would just start reading pick up
a book like the language of God by
Francis Collins a good place to start
explaining the the harmony between
between science and and a belief in God
although I would caution you though you
know I write language of God that's a
good book go pick that one up there are
other books like it but when you're
looking for in there are plenty of books
written by very intelligent very
well-respected and highly regarded
scientists who are also Christian like
Francis Collins so I would look at those
books I would caution you there are
there are other there's a whole other
sort of cottage industry out there of
some Christian who I some basic
basically hacks and charlatans who they
claim they're finding a harmony between
science and religion but what they're
really trying to do is debunk
established scientific facts because
those established scientific facts do
not work with their personal reading
absque ripshit the ones who do that
again are charlatans and hacks I would
stay far away from them you know if
you're reading a book and it's a
Christian who is trying to claim that
established scientific facts are not
facts put that to the side don't listen
to that but there fortunately as I said
are Allah
of scientists who are also Christian who
do not do that and who can who can look
at the world and say this is how the
world works I'm not denying that no
reason to deny it here's how it fits in
with a belief in God all right um this
is uh let's see this is from Nick says
Matt have you seen this
it's and then he gives me a link to a
USA Today article with the title girl
Power has burrow or Hasbro brings gender
pay gap debate to game night with new
Miss Monopoly and by the way if you
haven't heard of this this is a this is
a apparently a new version of Monopoly
where women if you're a woman playing
the game you start out with more money
than the men and I think I think it's
every time because usually a monopoly
every time you pass girl you get 200 but
every time you pass go in this version
the women get like 240 dollars and the
men still get 200 or whatever so that's
the game and then the email could just
as the father of two daughters I can't
think of anything more demeaning than
telling females they can't win unless
they are given a head start in this game
female players are given more money at
the start in each time they pass by they
pass go the article even feels the need
to explain that it is possible for boys
to win the game thought I'd share what
an embarrassment to our women in our
country yeah well I tell you what's what
what would be really embarrassing for me
I would love to to to play this game
because it's like it's like it's like
playing pick-up basketball with someone
when you just sprained your ankle
because there's really no losing if you
lose then you could always say well hey
just you know I have an injury what do
you expect but if you win then it's even
more impressive that you want so for me
I would love to play this game because I
figure if I still win even though I'm at
this disadvantage it makes me look even
better and it's even more embarrassing
for the competitors who had that
advantage and still we're not able to
win so for me if there if there was a
version of this game
men where men got more I wouldn't want
to play that game because I'd be way too
afraid I would still lose and how
humiliating is that so I would say this
just sets up a great challenge for guys
go out and play the game and win anyway
that'd be pretty funny of course it
makes no sense whatsoever we have I mean
the original Monopoly game is equality
right it's a definition of equality you
sit down you play the game everyone it's
the diet all have to roll the dice you
get the rules are the same for everybody
it works the same for everyone that is
equality that's how it's we're told that
we're it's claimed that that's how
feminists want the world to work with
equality and you discover yet again that
of course equality is not what they want
what they want is a head start what they
want is to be above everybody else and
this Monopoly game is just one small
rather petty but still I think very
telling sign of what feminists actually
won all right we'll leave it there
thanks everybody for watching Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by
Robert Sterling associate producer
alexia Garcia Del Rio executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer his
Austin Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wired
production copyright yellow wire 20 19
if you want to delve the depths of
leftist madness head on over to the
Michael Noel's show where we examine
what's really going on beneath the
surface of our politics and bask in the
simple joys of being right
you